it's been the best of times to commit a
lot of Crimes New York can't afford cops
while Crooks loot anything that stops
thieves now bored with hitting up brick
and mortar stores are now robbing
delivery vehicles this holiday season
turns out they hate the long lines like
the rest of us who can blame him in
Atlanta thieves ran into an Amazon truck
and stole multiple packages meanwhile a
FedEx driver in Tennessee told cops he
was stopped at a red light when several
cars drove up and blocked him see this
is why I never stop at red
lights thank you as many as 40 Crooks
hopped out and broke into the tractor
trailer stealing dozens of packages and
leaving several Strone all across the
street which would probably explain why
I still haven't got my workout shorts
yet or why KLA hasn't gotten that book
she
[Laughter]
ordered
or or why Joe Biden never got his
underwear but it seems like a stupid
kind of theft whatever you grab you have
no idea what's in that package it's just
like that club Jim took me to in
Thailand so nothing is off limits
anymore it's been a free-for-all in
stores across the country and now
delivery trucks are also targeted what
are we law-abiding citizens supposed to
do now do we start making our own Goods
at home I've already started look I made
a
lamp and a foot
stol and here's my new Guest
House meanwhile the NYPD is putting a
hiring freeze on new recruits because of
budget cuts fueled by a multi-billion
dollar migrant crisis this is bad since
the department already is struggling to
replace 3,000 uniformed cops who've
retired or quit since 2019 a police
Union Leader says this hiring freeze is
going to turn the NYPD Staffing crisis
into a public safety disaster it's true
pretty soon there will be no cops to
strip at my holiday
party I know I'm the real victim here
Heather all right this is what drives me
nuts okay so you when Target was
targeted their stores they just shut
them down they didn't put up a fight
they had these looting gangs come in
they didn't do anything they just shut
the stores down in Harlem and Oregon
wherever now you have the the delivery
people getting targeted when will the
companies or the insurance companies
actually stand up and say something well
it's interesting you mentioned Target
they I I'm not going to bore you with
stats but they had their earnings this
week CEO Brian Cornell said look
customers are thankful that we put up
these glass I don't think they're
bulletproof but like glass protectors
for all of the merchandise especially
out in Queens they're doing it and the
customers are saying this is great
because they had no inventory on the
Shelf there was no stuff to buy and you
know what as a consumer it's going to
cause the prices to go up it already has
because of the theft it's not just
inflation so first you think all right
I'll have a brick and mortar store ah
that didn't work during the BLM riots in
Chicago and New York and so now you're
moving to e-commerce and the poor look
at the poor helpless woman of the Amazon
driver what about her what when is Jeff
Bezos is going to take a stance and say
this is this is not working we need to
keep our employees safe and um so you
are against lady truck drivers no no I
but I think she has a case to bring to
the company to say hey I feel unsafe and
you have to do more or at least take a
stronger stance of in favor of Law and
Order D it's the one it's the one area
you're hearing nothing from the
corporations and it's because insurance
is taking care of it and they're scared
Andrew is this affecting your uh your
businesses at all yeah you know what's
funny in the restaurant industry it's
all D and dash right so that's actually
become like a whole coordinated effort
amongst various groups and they talk
about it online so we got to catch that
early I'm going to actually just start
pre-charging everybody who walks in the
door and uh and then providing bad food
and bad service uh that's the model
right because that's the US government
yeah so but but you know
what with with with this story with this
story I'm going to tell you and call me
callus is that I actually have no
sympathy I'm glad it's gone up the chain
and I'm glad it's hitting Amazon and
FedEx now and let me tell you why 20 to
20 2020 to 2022 FedEx $3 million to
Democrats Amazon $16 million to
Democrats they pay for this stuff soft
on Democrats and here we are this they
they bought this policy exactly so now
they got to live with it live with it
it's better than a porch Pirates right
because those are individuals who get
hit let Amazon get it Kat um how how do
you how are you going to make do if you
can't order things what's going to
happen to your life wither away and die
yes I know
I'm kind of close already you are uh I I
think it's the criminals they are a
little impressive though I mean the
coordinated effort I mean do they is it
online I mean is it emails is it Zoom
meetings that they're doing how how do
they all know I mean I think honestly
that looking at the body of work you
would really you could hire them to do
event planning yeah except for I'd be
worried they might steal from me but
other than that what if they applied
themselves in any other way it's true
this takes a lot of work and again the
percentage of success taking blind
products that you don't know it can't be
that good I mean it's like they steal
from me what are they gonna get well
let's not go bet revisit that pants you
know um Jim can I read another question
from uh one of my writers sure Greg
let's hope this one is less hurtful and
more helpful
Jim Jim you do stand up in the city as a
small and vulnerable
man do you ever feel unsafe leaving your
near empty
shows or do you have a tactic for
keeping the crazy people away from you
um that's a really really good long and
very specific question I'm really glad I
wasn't prepared for it so just Wing an
answer and being small and insignificant
um no I'm actually preferring an emptier
room because there's less people that
can harm me um for the poor show that I
put on and what was the rest of that
long wait a minute but don't you find
this whole thing weird that like why are
they stealing like from they don't even
know what's in the stuff that's the
hopefully someone got a stool sample
that was on its way to a
doctor coland
guard guard and honestly customers who
had their boxes taken off that FedEx
truck are still going to get them faster
than if they were mailed through the US
Post
Office they damaged another one of my
kiss
posters it actually seems like it' be a
really good game show like you get
what's inside the Box yeah yeah and when
if palro could host it it said they
caught I I think the police caught three
of the thieves uh in Memphis and they
said the car smelled like marijuana and
the guy said we didn't steal it we found
the boxes on the street we just picked
them up they were just sitting there wow
you believe that no I think they're
probably lying yeah and by the way
they're never going to stop this to keep
truckers safe I mean they haven't been
able to protect Domino's delivery people
yeah how long have Chinese food delivery
people been getting robbed You're not
going to stop people from doing this
yeah just wanted to end the segment on a
l
thank
you all right I love this up next can a
comedian show promise while looking like
a Donis hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else